Revisit and have a certain resolutions and
and just join in this, loving, creative spirit.
We'd love to talk to you
And you you know what this is about
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Marvel and Sony have revealed more plans
for Spider-Man 4,
and it turns out it involves
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield's
versions of Spider-Man
returning in addition to kingpin in Daredevil,
which sounds totally crazy, I would not have expected
Tobey and Andrew to come back.
So soon based on the way they ended Spider-Man.
No way home with that taxing of him
leaving his new apartment.
and a ton of questions
about what this means that will break it all down.
It turns out it's part of some of the larger issues
that Marvel is having with Sony behind the scenes about
exactly what the story of the movie is going to be
in, how this is going to play out through secret wars
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There is a bunch of Spider-Man stuff
happening really soon.
Like we do have that Madame Web movie.
It will be full more Ben time.
we've also got Venom three, the Kraven movie
and that Spider-Man freshman year TV series,
which now
they're calling Friendly Neighborhood Spider-Man
with a version of Charlie Cox's
Daredevil, Benedict Cumberbatch coming back.
There's a lot of MCU stuff happening during that,
but it's meant to be a multiverse.
Shows so we should start getting trailers
for that stuff later this year. ba.
Based on current events,
they're on track to release Spider-Man four in 2026.
It would have been 2025,
but all the strikes delayed everything about a year.
in the real News
everyone's talking about this week is Marvel
and Sony's competing plans
for the actual story of the movie.
Completely different stories.
and it turns out it's Sony who apparently wants
to make Spider-Man for another major multiverse movie
with universe ending Consequence is bringing back
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
as main characters in the movie with way more scenes
than they had in Spider-Man No Way Home.
Like they'd be much bigger characters
in the movie in general.
this is actually Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
talking about coming back.
I don't want to say like close the chapter,
but revisit and have a certain resolution
and and just join in this like,
loving, creative spirit.
so when Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man teased
that he wanted to fight an alien after Tobey Maguire,
Tom Holland referenced his venom in Thanos.
Sony was intending
on paying that off in Spider-Man four.
Apparently in it turns out part of the reason
why Sony wants things to go this way is is
they can actually just say that
Tom Holland is the Spider-Man of all their Sony
spin off movies like The Venom Universe,
They want to connect those Venom movies,
all those spin off movies that are happening
in that separate universe with everything in the MCU.
so, you know,
they already kind of canonized the larger spider-verse
like every Spider-Man movie to the larger
MCU multiverse.
Sony wants to make that more of like a literal thing
where you see Tom Holland's Spider-Man
showing up in all their spin off movies
A lot of us expecting them
to try to pay that off during like Venom three
or during one of the Sony Spider-Man movies.
I just put Andrew Garfield in the Sony
Spider-Man movies and make him the Spider-Man
of that Venom universe
But it sounds like this is the real reason
why they had that Venom crossover in the Spider-Man
No Way Home Post-Credits scene
in originally Tom Hardy's Venom was supposed to be
a bigger crossover character in the movie.
If you don't about the deleted scenes.
I've done a couple of videos about this a couple of
years ago after the movie came out in theaters
Originally, Tom Hardy's Venom was actually meant
to be in that final fight at the Statue of Liberty.
He was going to travel to New York City.
So when he's telling the bartender
in that post-credits scene,
I should really go to New York City
and talk to this Spider-Man about all these problems.
in the original version of the movie,
before they got Andrew Garfield
and Tobey Maguire to sign on to the film,
Tom Hardy was going to be a much bigger character,
sort of filling the gaps left by Tobey in Andrew.
he would have had a bunch of actual scenes
with Tom Holland's Spider-Man on screen.
So that's basically how they were going
to give the Spider-Man symbol to the Venom symbiote.
were actually going to share scenes together
in that big final fight
that's also why you see all the deleted scenes
of Tom Holland's Spider-Man in the symbiote suit.
Turns out that's how he was going to get the symbiote
and now they're making it sound like Sony
wants to go for Symbiote Saga with Tom Hold Spider-Man
starting in Spider-Man four
instead of waiting till later.
Movies and just have Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
in Andrew Garfield.
Be part of that.
You have the picture. Tobey Maguire Spider-Man.
Remembering everything from Spider-Man three.
Like, I've been through a version of this before.
Like, Yes, we've done all this.
This is how you deal with this symbiote.
the funny thing about this, too,
is Sony actually kind of set up some interesting
twist connecting Tobey Maguire's venom
with Tom Hardy's venom.
Some of you probably realize this after the Last Venom
movie came out.
during the venom,
let there be carnage Post-Credits scene.
The symbiote implied that all symbiotes
share a hive mind across the multiverse.
so the symbiote makes it sound like it had access to
and knows all the memories
from Tobey Maguire's venom in Spider-Man three.
They're not the same symbiote,
but because they share memories across the multiverse.
Tom Hardy's symbiote remembers
the events of Spider-Man three as if it were him.
They're doing all those things
and that's why he remembered Spider-Man
when he had his mask on and saw him on television.
the whole idea is that
he didn't know who Tom Holland was,
but he did recognize the Spider-Man suit.
That's why he said that guy
during the theatrical cut of Spider-Man, No Way Home.
You just see Tom Hardy's venom having already been
pulled to the MCU by Doctor Strange, his first film,
Paying Off the Venom Let There Be Carnage Post-Credits
scene when that spell would have actually happened.
Like we're seeing the spell go down in his post-credits
scene In the bar here is meant to be in Mexico.
That's where the hat is,
because that's where he was in the venom.
Let there be carnage. Post-Credits
scene like that's where this beach was.
So it was like he just wandered to the hotel bar.
After getting used to the MCU.
He leaves a piece of the symbiote is Doctor Strange.
His second spell sends him
and everyone else back to their original universes
and they reveal that the symbiote is alive
and moving on its own,
treating it kind of like the child of the Venom
symbiote in the way the carnage was.
Like a totally different personality
from Tom Hardy's Venom.
if you didn't realize, too,
I think this is a set up the idea that Tom Holland
can actually be the voice of his version of the Venom
symbiote,
what they did with the new Tom Hardy Venom movies
is they establish that Tom Hardy himself
does the voice of his venom and they just alter
the voice to make it sound like an alien voice.
so when they got to Venom let there be carnage they did
the same thing with Woody Harrelson in Carnage.
He did the voice of the carnage symbiote.
They just altered it a little bit
so it sounded more alien.
see you to picture Tom Holland's voice
sounding all flamed up in Alien.
in at least originally,
I think most of us assume Marvel
and Sony would just pay off that little symbiote piece
there in some future movie with no definitive answer
on when that movie would happen.
I think at the time, most of us assumed that Marvel
would take him back to basics
and he'd be more of a street level friendly
neighborhood.
Spider-Man in Spider-Man four.
Just the way they ended that movie.
end, I think most of us agreed
that they'd probably be better off waiting
till Avengers
Secret Wars to give Tom Holland the symbiote
so they could be more comic book accurate
because that's how he got the symbiote originally.
Like why not just do the comics?
but apparently this drama between Marvel and Sony right
now, Kevin Feige wants Spider-Man 4
to be more ground level friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man movie with a brand new Spider-Man
villain from the comics,
and then Kingpin and also Daredevil.
but on the other side of things,
Sony wants the movie to be this huge multiverse
Avengers level film again
with Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
coming back like if you thought The Spider-Man
No Way Home was a big deal.
They want to escalate things even further
bringing back Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield.
I think in Kevin Feige's
version of Spider-Man four, Tobey and Andrew
don't come back until at least Secret Wars.
There might be some Easter eggs in Deadpool three,
like some funny Easter eggs
from their Spider-Man movies, but I don't think
they actually appear on screen until Secret Wars.
but here's the problem.
You have to remember that
Marvel and Sony share control of Spider-Man.
So it's not as simple as just one of them deciding
what's going to happen.
They the powers
that be actually have to agree in a room.
What the movie's going to be pretty soon.
They have to actually start working on the movie
pretty soon if they want to get it out by 2026.
So let me know in the comments.
Would you rather have a big multiverse level Spider-Man
four with Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
coming back in a bigger way,
more symbiote saga stuff, more full blown Sinister Six?
Or would you rather have a more ground
level Spider-Man four
with Daredevil Kingpin in
maybe a couple of new Sinister Six characters?
In fact, what they should probably do
is just have Kingpin be the person
to hire the Sinister Six inside the MCU
and put that team together.
Kevin Feige did say the Daredevil Born Again
was going to influence the plot of Spider-Man four.
And if he's going to be mayor of New York City,
he's going to have a lot of power.
it would actually be a fairly simple thing for them to
do to say that he's going to hire all those villains.
I think people would dig seeing
Kingpin and Spider-Man and Daredevil
going at it in the film and, besides all the Tobey
Maguire Andrew Garfield stuff, we have learned
more about what's actually going on with the movie.
Zendaya is coming back as her version of MJ
should be a main character again,
despite Doctor Strange, a Spell
and everything that happened in the Spider-Man
No Way Home ending in Post-Credits scenes.
A lot of people online were confused by this detail,
like, wait a minute, what does that mean?
That the ending of Spider-Man,
No way home doesn't mean anything? No.
why? She's still a main character.
If Peter had all memory of their past together
erased from her mind to protect her,
like, literally, she has no idea that Peter Parker
as a person exists in the movie
Just because they couldn't think of a way fast enough
to fix the tears in the multiverse
without erasing all knowledge of him
from everyone's minds.
So bring her back in.
The story is a main kind of walks that twists back
just slowly.
It means that they'll continue being around each other,
whether he plans to be around her or not.
she's just continue to be part of his orbit
while he's trying to be
Spider-Man and be Peter Parker
and go to college during the day.
early theory is that he'll probably wind up having
to save her a couple of times and he'll be around her
during the day and things between them
will play out similarly to the way they did before,
where she starts to notice
weird inconsistencies and coincidences.
And she figures out that he is Spider-Man
all by herself.
Again, we'll probably learn more about the movie
pretty soon and we'll probably get trailers for that
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man TV show in the other
Spider-Man related movies that are happening.
Pretty soon,
I will do at least a couple videos for Madame Web.
Who knows what's going to happen with that movie?
will probably get a new Kraven trailer in a Venom
three trailer after Matt and Web comes out in theaters.
there's all kinds of reports
about how Madame Web has changed behind the scenes
because there's like a young version of Uncle Ben.
And don't worry, I'll get into that during more Madam
Web videos because it sounds fascinating.
Like what is Sony thinking with this movie?
What is going on here?
if you thought all the Easter Eggs in the morbius
trailers were confusing, don't you worry.
It's going to get even worse during Madame Web,
they just announced
more Marvel Netflix defenders characters coming back
during Daredevil Born again.
Click here for that brand new teaser
and click here for my brand new Deadpool 3 video.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!